so
just by way of introduction i think i
know many of you i'm jeremy utley
i'm a company harry claibon and then our
amazing team catherine segovia
and zhao are in the background making
everything happen as well
um so welcome to the masters of
creativity series session one
uh let's see i'll kick it off i'm going
to try to share my screen and perry just
let me know if that actually works okay
well the good news is if you want to
follow along and chat i dropped in the
deck you can download it
so if that's easier for you and you want
to do it that way or
you want to grab our materials you know
please do
yeah you know where uh perry is the kind
of guy if you ever sit by perry on an
airplane he's fast forwarding through
most movies
if you want to fast forward through this
talk you can actually download the
slides at this link and you can you can
go at your own speed
unfortunately you can't get us to talk
faster but you can at least
take a sneak peek and look ahead but uh
we're excited to uh to be with you all
today i want to start for those of you
who we don't know we want to tell you a
little bit about where we're coming from
and what led us actually to want to host
this talk series
awesome so a little bit of our
background we have so many interesting
past uh students
um of many different classes here so
these you've probably come through one
of these windows here
so uh if you think about the work we do
with students at stanford
along with catherine we run this program
leading disruptive innovation there's a
few of you
past students there we call it d
leadership
is the class and it's a it's a class
that we actually put students
into organizations um to lead change
efforts
using design tools and it can be a lot
of fun and
pretty wild and then the other one is um
launch pad
which is an accelerator using design
methods to launch
businesses for profits it's been around
11 years
so many companies but visit the website
and take a look at that if you're
interested and there's
lots of sort of interesting tools and
techniques related to
the early work there i see a few of the
founders
even from this year in the in the group
today so welcome
and then with executives and
professionals we do
boot camps or other types of programs
that are intense programs that happen at
stanford or online
that are um synchronous and um involved
catherine is a big part of that joust
would be part of that we put on these
huge efforts and we just uh just did one
a few weeks ago
and then stanford online which i think
there's many of you here that came
through the sime program
which is a program we invite you to look
at that that goes through
all the tools and techniques of design
as well as leading design
that's available at stanford online so
welcome i think everybody came through
one of those
windows most likely
i'm going to try to hit the eraser here
i don't know if that how that works boom
look at that nailed it
buck welcome from s i and e good to have
you with us
um so perry just shared a little bit of
the various windows that folks might be
coming through
one of the things that we have been
curious about is what are the tools that
folks lean on
and increasingly we're finding that some
of the tools and some of the entryway
points
that we have established through
executive education and other programs
to the d
school are getting a little worn you
might notice the hexagons are starting
to look a little tired
and we think less and less in terms of
this kind of hexagon driven uh
uh formulaic recipe driven approach if
you think if you think back to where
perry and i at what period i looked like
when we started with the hexagons
we were we were barely out of high
school practically okay
a lot has changed surgery i've been
through multiple pairs of glasses and
major surgery for crying out loud
and also that that photo of you jeremy i
still think just maybe audience vote how
much does he look like george costanza
with the vest on i think i think
personally a lot
it's the costanza photo please drop it
in chat if there's any other crazy
characters drop it in chat
but one of the things that we have
observed as we've been doing this work
inside organizations with graduate
students is there's this
focus on the sprint and by the way we we
value the sprint quite a bit
uh the idea of a short burst of high
intensity work
if you're coming from launch pad you
know we value this brand we're often
getting folks to sprint but we find that
that
basically reducing the the design
thinking driven approach
to a sprint is like telling somebody who
needs to come up with ideas
especially good ideas the ideas they can
implement and commercialize
it's like saying just grab a couple
ideas from the grocery store on your way
home
with the jug of milk and with the you
know with the bunch of
kale pick up a couple ideas too and
increasingly as we're immersed in
organizations as we're connected with
you all as our alums we're finding
it's not really how innovation works and
it's not really how creativity works
creativity if we have to think about a
different metaphor from the grocery
store it's more like a garden
and you're cultivating a set of
behaviors and attitudes and practices
and mindsets
and there's a lot more attention on a
daily basis
less in terms of sprinting and more in
terms of what we would think
of as practice if you like this front
metaphor then you might think about
the daily activities as stretching
and as training and as warming up
sprinting is great it's very important
we love it
but unless your life is marked by
a set of warm-ups and stretches and
practices
you're probably going to pull a hammy if
you start sprinting right and you've
probably seen that in the context of
your work it's just like
drop and give me a 400. you go uh right
now
like i haven't even stretched right a
lot of times creative action and
innovation efforts are kind of reduced
down to that start sprinting now
immediately go
and it doesn't have respect for the
system
that a creative mind lives in and what
the practices
and attitudes to cultivate that creative
mindset actually are
so we kind of want to take a step back
from design practice and even from
innovation itself
and talk about the the system and the
environmental factors that enable
creativity individual and team
creativity to flourish so
establishing our sort of premise for
this series is that
creativity is a craft and you hone it
through practice then that what does
that make us jeremy
well it makes us kind of like personal
trainers so
we'll date ourselves a little bit here
with saturday live funds in france
to pump you up um uh it's hysterical if
you don't know what we're talking about
google hans and franz saturn it live
dana carvey it is hysterical um anyway
so
but the idea is thinking about personal
trainers work directly with you and sort
of almost find a way for these
tools and techniques to to fit into your
life and that's what we think of these
sessions as not
what jeremy said like this perfect
project i'm going to use all these tools
but actually really and we we hope you
see today discreet techniques that work
against all kinds of different things in
your life whether group activities or
individual activities personal life
professional life
that you can apply directly so the
series itself
we're going to be doing four four
different sessions
you are in the input obsession session
uh we'll cover collaboration
experimentation and updating your
creative
operating system uh to trademark
you know us today because we just came
up with that before this talk
um but the the whole idea is
really sort of circling around this idea
of practice and these would be different
lenses
different sort of categories of
techniques
to build your practice around creativity
so part of the part of the fundamental
myth is that creativity is about output
we mentioned this in kind of our
correspondence
leading into this session most folks
when they think about creativity they
think about
a creative outcome and that's not
the way to think about creativity uh
author arthur coastler
did some research in the mid 1960s and
this is one of
my favorite definitions creativity is
the collision
of apparently unrelated frames of
reference
and you can think about one frame is
your brain today a different frame is
your brain tomorrow etc but
what you're colliding your brain with
the outcomes of those collisions are
creative outcomes
but instead of thinking about creativity
being the
output of your effort what we would
recommend is saying
creativity is actually a function of the
inputs
you're feeding the system and what we've
observed among
highly successful and creative
individuals
is that they are relentless and
focused and rigorous about cultivating
inputs of mind
in order to lead to creative outputs so
a lot of us who are not
experienced creatives or or we don't
come from creative fields
when we hear about creativity we think
about drawing or we think about the arts
or we think about
some kind of outcome that looks
beautiful and what we know
actually from immersing in organizations
and and immersing with creative
professionals
is that creatives are way more concerned
with their inputs
as an example my wife's a fashion
designer and she goes on these
inspiration trips to new york and paris
i i think it's because she likes
macarons but the truth is
she's she's looking at color she's
looking at silhouette
she's looking at form she comes and she
makes these inspo boards
you know and i remember as an mba when
she was making inspo boards i'm going
what are you doing what is the purpose
of that like that i can't put that in a
spreadsheet i can't run a pivot table on
the inspiration board and i love
maybe a 2x2 it's hard to fit an
inspiration board into a 2x2 right
and yet as i watch her i see that's
what's fueling her craft
i had the opportunity to teach a class
with a hip-hop artist
called lecrae last fall
and our teaching team was giving our
students an assignment
where we were telling them you need to
go out and get inspiration you've got
this problem but before you try to solve
it get inspired
and i could see the blank stares on our
students faces and i could sympathize
as a as a former mba i could see
creativity's not even or sorry
inspiration isn't even a topic
on the radar let alone you know anything
worth doing
and i just turned to lecrae and i said
look craig how do you think about
inspiration i mean he's won
multiple grammys he's a you know wildly
productive prolific
entrepreneur and artist and
i love what he said he just said
inspiration's a discipline
and to me it stood in such stark
contrast to
how our students that we were we were
trying to exhort
to go get inspiration thought about that
topic i think for most people if you
think about
this topic of inspiration you think
about the cheesy poster
in the corporate hallway it's like
motivation or teamwork and
that's inspiration that's not when we're
talking about inspiration and the
discipline of inspiration we're not
talking about plastering the hallways
with
cheesy posters that's not what we mean
by this word so we want to try to redeem
the word
and give it a new definition yeah you're
otherwise you're not in the dentist's
office that's where i see those posters
they always remind me the dentist's
office the waiting room
um anyway so if you want to point jeremy
this is this is the point
i'm going to point to the side jeremy
there we go screen grab
okay that's funny um it's this you so if
you're
if you want to the premise of kind of
what we're going to talk about here is
in different ways it's you're pursuing
unexpected inputs and if you're going
through your day
pursuing these unexpected inputs and
leaving yourself open for them
that's the that's the creative practice
we want to help you
hone as we pump you up today
and it's really unexpected is actually
an important word before perry
palms you up because that's how a mid
imagination is stimulated imagination is
stimulated by surprising inputs
and and the rea i read a research report
i know i'm a nerd but i do that
and it it pictured an organization like
a sphere
and it says the vast majority of the
organization has no contact with
the outside world only the surface does
but that's the only part of the
organization that's
likely to come in contact with an
unexpected input
and i like that as a metaphor that if
you want to stimulate your imagination
you're not you need to seek out you need
to be deliberate about finding things
you don't already know
and it requires a trip to or a short
circuit of
the tendencies in much of organizational
life which is around
reinforcing what we do already know and
doubling down
and and going in things that we've
already thought about
et cetera et cetera anyway perry i
interrupted your your pump up moment
that's all right it's kind of i can't do
it now that'd be weird so
let's just move on you wanna you wanna
restart should we research
maybe the next slide please all right
so we'll break down these tools into uh
ways of creating connections and it
reminds me just briefly
there's a great lecturer a professor at
uh stanford robert sapolsky wrote a book
called behave it's amazing
and i think the team or myself i can't
remember we had a meeting with him and
he
he talked about sort of new ideas coming
from he's a neuroscience and
and primatologist and all these things
but talked about the
the act of a new idea is a lot of times
just clashing together
you know two things you haven't clashed
together before so jeremy's point about
something unexpected
coming together with maybe another
problem you're trying to solve
creates a bunch of new connections that
just you
yield new ideas things that are new to
you so that's the
that's the idea we're gonna cover um two
techniques um
in this category are three techniques
bonus technique
this is real time people this is this is
happening right now
i'm here i'm just trying to throw a
barrier off so i'm changing the slides
in the background real time he has the
slide deck i have a copy that's now out
of date so
i'm like the old operating system now
let's talk about analogies first so
analogies well you go ahead and jeremy
and run it but without much
setup so we want to we want to actually
do
like this nerdy thing where you read the
screen um
this is a this is an insight related
problem
uh it's called actually there's an
official title of it
it's called dunker's radiation problem
you might be familiar with it if you're
familiar with obscure 1930s research
it was written about in a couple recent
books and we when we stumbled across it
we just thought it was such a good
example
of a challenge well should we have
catherine do a voiceover without the
camera on then it's really interactive
oh catherine you want to yeah i like
catherine you ready
she's got a she's she's got the radio
voice let's hear it catherine
suppose you are a doctor faced with a
patient who has a malignant stomach
tumor
it is impossible to operate on this
patient
but unless the tumor is destroyed the
patient will die
there is a kind of ray that can be used
to destroy the tumor
if the rays reach the tumor all at once
in a sufficiently high intensity
the tumor will be destroyed
unfortunately
at this intensity the healthy tissue
that the rays pass through on the way to
the tumor will also be destroyed
at lower intensities the rays are
harmless to healthy tissue
but they will not affect the tumor
either
what type of procedure might be used to
destroy the tumor
with the rays and at the same time avoid
destroying the healthy tissue
it's on you to exercise to excise the
tumor
and save the patient but the rays are
either too powerful
or too weak how can you solve it
so you're thinking about this problem
let's actually think about it for a
moment
don't be concerned if you can't solve it
only about 10 of people solve it
initially
again these are people from the 1930s
probably it's different in the 2020s
i don't know but uh but uh radio
operator
would you mind to continue
while you're thinking a little story to
pass the time
there once was a general who needed to
capture a fortress in the middle of a
country from a brutal dictator
if the general could get all of his
troops to the fortress at the same time
they would have no problem taking it
plenty of roads that the troops could
travel radiated out from the fort like
spoke wheels
but they were strewn with mines so only
small groups of soldiers could safely
traverse
any one road the general came up with
the plan
he divided the army into small groups
and each group
traveled a different road leading to the
fortress
they synchronized their watches and made
sure to converge on the fortress at the
same time
via their separate roads the plan
worked the general captured the fortress
and overthrew the dictator
have you saved the patient yet just one
last story while you're still
thinking years ago a small town fire
chief
arrived let me put that in the right
order a small town fire chief
arrived at a woodshed fire concerned
that it would spread
to a nearby house if it was not
extinguished quickly
there were no hydrants nearby but the
shed was next to a lake
so there was plenty of water dozens of
neighbors were already taking turns with
buckets throwing water on the shed
but they weren't making any progress the
neighbors were surprised when the fire
chief yelled at them to stop
and to all go fill their buckets in the
lake when they returned
the chief arranged them in a circle
around the shed and on the count of
three
had them all through their water at once
the fire was immediately dampened
and soon thereafter extinguished the
town gave the fire chief a pay raise
as a reward for quick thinking
can we can we uh on so we're all looking
at each other let's give katherine some
fireworks applause for that reading i
mean that was
that was just marvelous thank you story
time for executives
story time exactly really is no
fast forward button no but so
so what's interesting is yeah some of
you are getting it in the chat now which
is great
um the interesting thing is the is the
data here
only about 10 of people solve the
problem initially
um if if they hear both of the the
problem and the fortress story about
thirty percent
solve the problem if they hear both
and the fire chief story half solve it
and then if they're given
those and told to use them to help
solve the radiation problem eighty
percent salt
uh solve the problem what does this tell
us
it tells us that you have to have a
mindset
of looking to apply an analogy there are
rich
learnings in other fields but they only
yield themselves up to you
if you're looking and if you're having
the attitude of i almost think about it
is having the attitude of i'm gonna
force a fit
what if i assume for a moment that there
must be a connection between this
analogous situation
and the problem i'm trying to solve what
might i learn from it
and a lot of times trying on that
forcible collision to use coastler's
word
trying on the collision yields
unexpected insights and possibilities
that even enter
that wouldn't have come to me if i
hadn't been willing to entertain it but
we've seen it this isn't just a research
phenomenon we've actually seen this in
practice
in many organizations and it's a highly
effective strategy
oh jeremy i'm going to tell this story a
second but i'm also going to put
jeremy's blog link in there if you want
to learn more also it just jeremy needs
a couple ad dollars there
go ahead i don't run traffic but but
you're giving me an idea i should set
that up next time
generally anyway so for um a bunch of
you
came through s i e this is a this is a
story we tell on that so this will be
review for you
uh new to others um we we had the
pleasure working with a
team out of fairchild semiconductor many
many years ago and
used a technique using analogy and
timely because you've been reading about
these headlines were those shortages of
semiconductors well the challenge they
had was that um
small small customers would get shorted
on their orders and cause
major major challenges at that point for
example tesla was actually a small
customer many of the car companies are
technically small customers
because they're using one or two you
know chips from a supplier per car but
imagine they don't have it you're seeing
what's happening they can't even you
know build a whole car
um so anyway they had this challenge of
interruptions and supply
affecting smaller customers radically
and they sought to understand and use
analogy
to to drive new ideas and they thought
for so what they did is they they went
into the world with this problem and
said
okay where are places we can learn um
about
businesses or people that deal with
routine interruptions
but manage to still supply their
customers and one of the places they met
it's a great story they still tell us
about going to a florist and saying how
in the world do you promise somebody
flowers
two weeks from now when they're
perishable you know you might have a big
you know order come in the day before
like how the world do you deal with that
and the florist explained we have
relationships with farmers and we sort
of see what they're farming and what's
potentially going to be in and we we
sort of work with that
to manage expectations of our customers
in advance
and they took that back and they used
that as sort of an input to their design
process
and ultimately launched a supplier it's
called digikey
it's on the internet but it's a it's a
different kind of supply
uh portal for their customers that
allows them to see
production coming from fairchild but
also to see suppliers from other vendors
even so they could
they realize what they want to do with
those smaller customers is make sure
they like the florist
they have a perspective as to what's
going to be available and what might not
be available
so a good example of like going out in
the world and
seeking these unexpected inputs and by
being open they suddenly
noticed we can learn a lot from a
florist and use that an
analog like the problem jeremy just went
through
to drive their thinking and get to new
places they wouldn't have got to before
yeah it's i i remember distinctly the
team coming back
they were very skeptical when we said no
go to a massage
go to a nail salon go to a sushi bar and
they're like
you're kidding right but they came back
the teams came back
super energized catherine was their
members as well they were super
energized because they're learning from
a florist
meaningful insights about supply chain
management and when you abstract a level
you say yeah actually it's not an
unfamiliar challenge
and the fact that it's unfamiliar in
your industry
doesn't mean that it's unfamiliar to the
world and a lot of times if you're
thoughtful about
and if you've taken the innovation
strategy course in the sie certificate
you probably know
this method intimately because we walk
through it step by step but
the world will yield up lots of amazing
insights
to the person who's looking there's a
little bit of research
that we've done on analogy that i just
figured i'd mention here but
an analogy empirically speaking leads to
more
output than a generic prompt that's one
level
second level is multiple analogies
generate more output than a single
analogy does and then the third level is
the more distant the analogy the more
generative it is so you might think you
gotta stay close
or stay focused and actually a lot of
this cultivating inputs
is about entertaining the possibility of
a collision with something highly
unrelated or highly distant
yeah yeah and you think about those
executive teams they're saying well no
no no
i want to benchmark i want to look at
what our competitors are doing but
by going this this is critical like i
like that point jeremy by going beyond
to a florist that has
nothing whatever to do with our business
that's where the big idea came from
so uh um so again we're in this this
sort of driving connection
um this idea of a wonder wonder is
something that we now assign routinely
in our classes
um jeremy and i are known to do this
also on on a daily basis and they
the basic idea is if you have a clear
sort of frame
on a problem a clear thing you're
working on one of the best things you
can do
is actually step away so right now if i
said how do i make this talk more
interesting the best thing i could do is
walk outside
with just the idea of how do i make that
more interesting ruminate
go for a walk and uh by holding that in
my head that i'm i'm trying to be more
interesting i might
see a couple dogs playing i might get
inspiration from the outside world
and just drive more inputs it's it's
important you go out
with an objective and then i would bring
something with me we'll talk about
it bring up how to post it to a notebook
to write these things down
and and i i would sort of come back and
be able to um
have more material with which to
innovate you know this unrelented sort
of pursuit i'd have new
inputs to my practice to get inspired
jeremy does this we oftentimes are
working on something we'll say okay
let's both step away but
but hold each other accountable like
we're going to go work on this frame
jeremy truth be told does live close to
a mcdonald's that
does or a jack-in-the-box
i find i find that he has a lot of
milkshakes but um
anyway that's one little bonus to this
effort i would say
the viscosity of the milkshake just the
effort required just a pure mechanical
effort it just it's like it sucks ideas
into my head i mean it's really
it's true as you wonder that the key
thing is writing it down
and we'll get back to that at the end so
we said that we were going to cover a
third topic on
how do you how do you accelerate
connections
i love it the bonus topic but wait
period it's actually not a bonus topic
because
we realize there's so much interest in
these topics we said
let's make it its own talk next time so
there's
this is a teaser so sign up now yeah
exactly
sign up now 49.99 you will get and
you'll get a free gift with purchase now
we we wanted the the topic of
collaboration
and diverse perspectives and leveraging
and amplifying diverse perspectives
it's such a worthy topic it's actually
an entirely other session on its own
and we've learned a ton from amazing
leadership teams and
and design teams and innovation teams
and creatives that we've worked with
we just want to dedicate an entire talk
to that so it is a little bit of a
teaser but i would say
there's so many rich stories it's it's
not worth giving it a one minute
treatment it's worth giving it a
significant
uh treatment so we talked about
connection but now we want to talk about
something that's unexpected for folks if
you think about
input obsession disconnection
disconnection is actually a critical
part of realizing new connections
have you ever had this experience i i
feel like i'm
living in you know groundhog day these
days where i get to the end of the
meeting
and there's like five things that i
really need to attend to
and then immediately somebody else is on
my screen in the next meeting
and i totally forget all of the other
things that i
was just thinking about there's great
ideas there's stuff i need to take care
of right
and then and then that meeting
culminates and a bunch of other things
that then immediately get forgotten
right
without disconnection we don't harvest
the possibility of the connections that
we've been seeking
and part of when we talk about being
obsessed with inputs
part of what is required is that
creative thinkers and innovators
make space to make the connections that
happen in their minds
and not rush from thing to thing to
thing to think
it's really really hard to do this but
we find it's
absolutely critical to make the space
to realize connections our our brains
aren't efficient they're efficient in a
lot of ways you know you can't
power a brain size network or a brain
powered network with basically all the
power we have available at our disposal
so incredibly efficient in some sense
but they're actually driven by and
unexpected connections are driven by an
inefficient process that oftentimes
happens at a subconscious level
and as we're hyper efficiency oriented
driven from productivity
you know meeting to meetings to meeting
we fail to maximize those
connections one of our favorite uh
uh researchers amos tursky who is the
partner the research partner of danny
kahneman if he had lived he would have
been the co-winner of the nobel prize
with danny kahneman but they invented
the field of behavioral psychology and
behavioral economics the notion that
people aren't rational
is we have among others we have these
two incredible
uh incredibly brilliant gentlemen to
thank and
one time they devised a bunch of
incredibly insightful and creative
experiments part of their breakthroughs
was because their experimental design
was so creative you can read about this
mike lewis uh the author of the big
short and moneyball
he wrote a great book on them called the
undoing project if you're curious about
where this
psychology comes from but when somebody
asked chersky once
how did you and kahneman come up with so
many cool experiments this is what he
said we wasted time
and he said people waste years by not
being able to waste hours
and what and the joke around their
department they were
at a university in israel the joke
around their department is those guys
are laughing too much
it wasn't a joke it was more of a
comment of derision they're always
laughing they're always cutting up
and yet what they knew was that a little
bit of loose time was critical for them
to realize the value of new connections
and so i want to talk for a second about
a little bit of the dorky side of
psychology
so if you read the literature i mean
there's a bunch of different ways to
parse it so this isn't meant to be a
comprehensive or
perfect explanation but if you think
about what's happening
in the creative mindset there's a stage
of preparation
there's a stage of incubation there's a
stage of illumination which is the
aha moment right and then there's a
stage of verification
what we have observed casually this
isn't uh this isn't a clinical diagnosis
because i'm not a clin
i'm not a clinical psychologist but i
would say one of the most
short-circuited processes in the 21st
century
is incubation giving our brain
the soup space to connect things
and so when we talk about not just
connection but disconnection
part of the part of the underlying idea
there is that disconnection is
actually part of what fuels connection
and if we're not deliberate about
disconnecting we won't be able to
realize those new connections
we want to talk about or often times we
do it by accident and we think oh this
is just magical this happened this
illuminating moment just happened
in this other context i went out with my
kids and i did something and i just
suddenly
boom but it's we would this is so
interesting jeremy that i think if you
look at the
preparation and incubation that's maybe
you know i don't know
another talk boom bonus okay and
fifth in the masters of creativity
series barry claibon on preparation
uh catherine how's my voice there is
that okay i'm not i'm no catherine
segovia very
very radio thank you very radio so i
want to talk about three
very cool tactics that we've observed in
the lives of prolific
innovators discoverers scientists these
are almost
too crazy to be true i kid you not so
i'm excited
so again how do you get to disconnection
so the first is what we have
affectionately called the divergent
diversion and this was a tactic that we
stumbled upon
in reading walter isaacson's biography
of albert einstein
albert einstein's wife and son both
have a shared experience of einstein
many times he'd be
sitting frantically writing at his
journal working on equations
and then he would get frustrated he
would pace in his he had a little you
know chamber
in the upstairs of their house he'd be
pacing around and you know what he did
whenever he got really stuck on a
problem
he picked up his violin and he started
playing the violin and his son tells the
story of many times
he would hear the violin clatter and his
dad go i've got it
and he'd go rush back to the notebook
right but to me what's
awesome is about this example is
einstein didn't do it
for relaxation necessarily he wielded
the violin as a creative tool
when he was stuck he knew that a
meaningful way to advance
on the problem was to think about
something else or to
engage a different part of his
consciousness
and i love that image but that he's not
the only person who did things like this
there's another
incredible innovator i don't know is
anyone familiar with a guy named claude
shannon
he's a legendary innovator at bell labs
he
is the reason we can see one another on
the screen right now
he invented a little thing called the
bit the
the the notion that you can encode
information with ones and zeroes that
can be transmitted claude shannon
is our guy i think he has the most
referenced doctoral thesis of all time
okay he was a absolute genius and you
know what he was known to do
in the hallways of bell labs as they
were inventing the transistor and the
satellite and the laser
i kid you not you can't make it up he
would
juggle on his unicycle and he'd ride
around the hallways
juggling and people knew that's just
claude shannon you know and a lot of you
will probably write it off but you go
he's again he's wielding diversion
as a tool he knows when i'm stuck
approaching the problem in one way i
need to
give my brain time to kind of process
all the stuff that i've been taking in
and so for us one of the assignments
we've started giving to the i know d
leaders that are on this uh session
are familiar with this but we give the
assignment to play
go do something that you enjoy that
engages you
phys physically but take a notebook with
you
and have the discipline to know in the
back your mind you want to be leaving
some of these things in your working
memory you want to be processing
but pro but make progress by doing
something different
and we joke we joked with a group of
saudi executives recently who we gave
this assignment to
this is probably the only ivy league
education where you've been told to go
play video games or something right
and they loved it and they came back
blown away right
because we're so trained to when i got
to solve the problem i got to sit down
and think harder and work harder
rather than sometimes looking up lifting
up our heads and saying
what else can i do while i think about
this
and it's no wonder that insights happen
in the shower
or you know in on the commute right
i read something that said the bed the
bus and the bathtub
are the three you know there's a reason
the bed the bus and the bathtub
are often implicated in these stories of
innovation and it's
and if you're aware of that you can
wield those as tactics to your
advantage perry you want to talk about
this next one
oh yeah so um the idea of productive
procrastination
there is an amazing ted talk i'll drop
in the chat
um that adam grant
does and talks about this topic of
actually
um how do we say this like we we think
too many times you know i'm not solving
a problem and procrastinating and
wasting time wasting time
but holding a problem in your active
sort of working brain
while you're procrastinating and maybe
struggling with a little bit
is actually a great way to innovate and
drive innovation and realize that's part
of the process
you think about those early stages
that's absolutely that incubation
category
so next time you're procrastinating
think about it as
actually more productive time am i
holding still that problem in my head am
i actually
you know sort of maybe consternating a
bit on it in my procrastination
that's actually productive time that
you'll actually move forward
and then i think um the do you want to
talk about the
um bluma the the research i'll drop
this is a hilarious example where
actually grant
adam grant talks about he's writing his
book originals and he
and he got to this this notion of
procrastination as a meaningful tactic
and he said you know he's an incredibly
organized person he said i'm going to
try it
on for scythe and while he was
procrastinating he put it he put the
chapter in his drawer for a couple of
weeks
and he was reminded of the research of
uh zignarak a russian psychologist
who demonstrated how our working memory
continues
he said i never would have thought of
that if i hadn't chosen to procrastinate
this is kind of a meta realization that
we love
and so we again tell students
if you're going to procrastinate be
deliberate about
capturing and write down other ways of
solving the problem
that you've got in the back your mind
one important note
if you don't care about the outcome
procrastination
is poisonous if you really care about
the outcome
procrastination is a meaningful and
productive strategy
so that's not that's not that's not a
universal
um uh you know blessing upon
procrastination there is such thing as
bad procrastination
but it's useful to know that when we
actually care about something
procrastination is a meaningful way that
our uh
that our our subconscious can advance
and then the last tactic we want to talk
about
is taking this to the extreme obviously
but is actually sleeping on a problem
there's a german psychologist uh wagner
ulrich i believe i can post a link to it
later maybe but he he gave
sets of different sets of students
different kinds of insight problems and
analytical problems
and he gave them at different times of
day and night
and one of the things that he discovered
was for analytical problems
it didn't really matter when you gave
them but for
insight related problems for creative
challenges
if you gave a subject the opportunity to
sleep
before solving the problem they were two
i think
over two times more likely to identify
the insight
that solved the problem and this is a
great
there's there's a great story uh one of
one of the most prolific inventors of
all time
thomas edison over a thousand patents to
his name
there's uh there's a bit of folklore or
it's it's written up in books but you
can never know with people like this and
the things they do
but he had what he called his thinking
chair
and the way the story goes he would sit
down in the thinking chair
put two pie pans underneath both arms of
the chair
and then he would hold a metal ball in
each hand and he'd sit back to relax
and as he was dozing off his hands would
release and the balls would clatter into
the pie pans and wake him up
and he would tell an attendant standing
there what he was dreaming about
because he so valued the power of the
subconscious to get around some of the
associative barriers that are
predominant when your conscious brain is
working on something
i love he didn't call it his recliner he
didn't call it his napping chair he
called it his
thinking chair and what did he do in his
thinking chair
he annoyingly woke himself up from just
i mean i can't imagine how painful that
had to be i also read something recently
that salvador dali did a similar thing
he would use a spoon in his hand and he
would sit down and he would place a
pan and a metal pan underneath the hand
holding the spoon
and that's where a lot of the
surrealistic inspiration came from
is this kind of this dream state so it's
it's a good thing to be aware of i have
i i'll speak for
myself personally this is very practical
i keep
beside my bedside a stack of post-its
this is you're like of course you do you
work at the d school of course i'm not
surprised
and a sharpie and i kid and i've made
an agreement with myself as i was
talking to a uh to a
perry and i were talking to an executive
in ireland last week
and i like because he said a lot of
times when i'm surfing
ideas come to me and he uses this phrase
i love it and i'll borrow it and i'll
share it with you said
i've made a commitment to my
subconscious
to hold on to those ideas and i love
that phrase commitment to my
subconscious
and so what i uh what i've done is i
said to myself
if an idea strikes i don't care how
sleepy i am i'm gonna roll over and
write it down
and i actually had the experience and
then i've gotta i have a whole process
a whole system you know as nerds do
where i keep this
notebook in the back pocket of my jeans
at all times it's small enough that it
fits the back pocket it's thin enough
that i don't take it out
unlike costanza by the way full circle
perry
can i get a witness that was a good
reference and a good joke
unlike costanza it's thin enough that i
can keep it in my back pocket but then
i'll transfer whatever ideas come up
and i actually have two from last night
interestingly enough but what's funny is
my funny story
this actually happened the other day i
was
falling asleep we were working on this
project
i was falling asleep and an idea came
and my first thought was i know i tell
people to write down their ideas but
i know i shouldn't be a hypocrite but
i'm just so tired and
but i'm like no i gotta do it i gotta do
i gotta practice what i preach
and so i rolled over and you know it's
totally dark i don't even know if i'm
writing on the poster
i scroll this thing in the morning i
woke up and i thought of the idea
and i thought man i can't believe i
interrupted my sleep because i totally
remember it
and then i picked up my notebook what i
wrote down
was a completely different idea than
what i thought i remember
it was this amazing experience of the
idea that i have is really cool
and it's totally different from the idea
that i thought
was the idea i had so it's you know it's
like uh
the the men's hair club i'm not only the
president i'm also a member it's like
this stuff works in my life but it
brings us to a very important
uh conclusion statement which is the
discipline
of documentation we often say you've
often heard us if you've been at the d
school for any amount of time
if you don't write it down it didn't
happen uh
our mentor david kelly the founder of
the d-school he told
me an anecdote the other day he was
friends with the late robin williams and
he said robin williams would carry
a yellow legal pad with him everywhere
and he's writing down notes throughout
the day
i read a i read a biography of david
byrne who was one of the founding
members of the talking heads
and he was talking about how in his back
pocket he carried a dictaphone
all the time because he said he'd hear
something in the streets he'd hear a
beat or something and he'd want to
record it or he'd want to sing a melody
right
but there's this rigorous attitude of
you know just like you and we can think
as professionals in maybe quote unquote
non-creative fields
of course robin williams is writing down
ideas he's got a set that night
you know of course david byrne is taking
clips
he's got well is our job
to come up with new things is our job to
frame that email to uh give that piece
of feedback
to uh to engage the customer to secure a
repeat purchase to close the deal
why why don't we approach it with the
same level of diligence and rigor
the idea of capturing all the ideas that
come
we can start them later it's actually
not that different and so for that
reason
i i like to think we're all in the ideas
business
most of us most of us don't really know
it but if we're aware of it we say i'm
in the ideas business too
and you know what my job is is to write
down my ideas
i don't have to do all of them but if i
at least write them down i'll give
myself a fighting chance of discovering
something worth doing
and it's it's that simple it's it's but
i have found its
incredibly meaningful practice
personally and so i passed that on to
you all
the commitment to your subconscious is a
real thing it is annoying it
is painful at times i mean
my wife can tell you the number of times
i've gotten out of the shower stopping
wet i'm like ah it happened
again i'm writing down ideas but i've
made peace with it i'm in the ideas
business you know what we do when we're
in the ideas business
we write things down and we're focused
on
cultivating that input